one thing conservatives are starting to
get it right though
i and i hope that maybe the show has
played some role in it maybe
some some writing that we've been doing
has played some role in it
the gop governors are getting a little
bit tougher on the vaccine passport i've
said on this show this needs to be a
line in the sand there are 27 republican
governors in this country
and so far yet by as of yesterday as of
two days ago three of them had come out
against vaccine passports and we've been
hammering and hammering and hammering a
lot of other conservatives joined the
chorus
then we got a another republican
governor now we've got
gop governor brad little
in idaho who is coming out to prohibit
the so-called vaccine passports
this will bring him to join florida
texas and utah
little's order comes after new york has
started pushing in the other direction
and they want to start seeing these
vaccine passports
he says quote idahoans should be given
the choice to receive the vaccine we
should not violate idahoan's personal
freedoms by requiring them to receive it
vaccine passports create different
classes of citizens vaccine passports
restrict the free flow of commerce
during a time when life and the economy
are returning to normal
vaccine passports threaten individual
freedom and patient privacy i really
like this
you know terence williams their comedian
a friend of mine
terence tweeted the other day he said
you know look i'm not gonna get the
vaccine but it's not because of politics
i just don't want to grow a tail and a
third eye
this is basically saying i'm a little
skeptical of this vaccine look
vaccine seems to be working out just
fine but hey for me i'd rather not get
it it seems like it it came out very
quickly and
i'm young i'm healthy i don't really
want to get it and according to the
democratic governors terence
is basically a mass murderer for saying
that and he'll probably be kicked off
social media because you're not allowed
to make any jokes about the vaccine
if i talk about how you know all my
friends who got the vaccine are now my
personal wi-fi hot spots
their 5g flowing all through their
bodies if i make that joke i can be
kicked off of social media
and what the governors now are saying is
no that's a bridge too far
giving not just the government but big
tech and allegedly private businesses
the right to force you to inject
yourself with a very new vaccine
and then give them the right to force
you to show them your medical history
and give that medical history to big
tech companies it's a step too far
so here again i mean this looks pretty
good in idaho but we've got to keep the
feet to the fire here this cannot just
be about
the government coming out and saying
we're not going to mandate it it's
actually got to go further
it's got to say the companies can't
mandate it either we're going to
interfere in the allegedly free market
of the allegedly private businesses
to protect the constitutional rights and
the liberty
and the political traditions of
americans
that's what they have to do things are
moving in the right direction and that's
really great stuff
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content out there
[Music]
you